>> Tucker: WE'VE HAD A LOT TO
SAY ABOUT CONGRESSMAN MAXINE
WATERS ON THE SHOW, BUT SOMEHOW
SHE KEEPS GIVING US EXCUSES TO
SAY EVEN MORE.
IN 2002, SHE ATTENDED NATION OF
ISLAM CONVENTION, NOT MUCH
HAPPENED REALLY ACCEPT THIS.
SHORTLY AFTER CELEBRATING, LOUIS
FARRAKHAN BEGAN PRAISING
PALESTINIAN SUICIDE BOMBERS AND
THEN PRAISED IRAN FOR HAVING A
MAC HAVING ARMED THEM.
WATERS WASN'T BOTHERED BY THIS.
HE JOINS US TONIGHT.
IT'S LIKE YOU CAN'T EVEN BELIEVE
IT'S REAL.
I DON'T THINK THIS CAN RUN
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" TOMORROW.
WHY IS THAT?
>> OF COURSE IT'S NOT.
WITH THE LEFT, THEY HAVE DOUBLE
STANDARDS ON WHAT ACTUALLY IS
HATEFUL AND RACISM.
IF THEY HAVE DOUBLE STANDARDS.
THIS SHOULDN'T BE SURPRISING
ABOUT THE NATION OF ISLAM
BECAUSE THEY HAVE BEEN KNOWN TO
RAPE WOMEN WITHIN THE RELIGION.
THEY DISLIKE PEOPLE THAT LEAVE
THE FAITH.
JUST ASK MALCOLM X WHO GOT
ASSASSINATED BECAUSE HE DECIDED
TO LEAVE THE FAITH.
THIS IS THE PATTERN WITH THIS
ORGANIZATION.
THE LEFT HAS DIFFERENT STANDARDS
OF WHAT THEY FEEL IS HATEFUL.
WHAT THEY TEACH ON THE COLLEGE
CAMPUSES TODAY IS THAT IF YOU
ARE NOT IN POWER, WHICH I
CONSIDER OF A MINORITY NOT
EMPOWER, THEN YOU CAN'T BE
RACIST.
THIS IS GOING TO BE SOMETHING
THAT GOES ON FOR A LONG TIME
BECAUSE NO ONE IS STANDING UP
FOR FREE SPEECH.
NO ONE IS STANDING AGAINST THIS
HATEFUL RHETORIC.
WE TRIED TO REPORT IT EVERY DAY
AT THE LEADERSHIP INSTITUTE
CAMPUS REFORM, BUT A LOT OF THE
MAINSTREAM MEDIA IS NOT COVERING
THIS.
>> Tucker: I SHOULD JUST SAY
IN THE INTEREST OF TOTAL
DISCLOSURE AND HONESTY, I KNOW
SOME PEOPLE IN THE NATION OF
ISLAM WHO ARE REALLY NICE GUYS.
THERE IS NO DEFENDING THEIR CORE
BELIEFS, WHICH ARE RACIST BY
DEFINITION.
THEY THINK THAT GOD IS GOING TO
KILL ALL WHITE PEOPLE.
THAT'S RACIST TO SAY.
ISN'T IT A LITTLE PATRONIZING TO
FOR THE PRESS TO GIVE MAXINE
WATERS A PASS IN ASSOCIATED WITH
SOMETHING LIKE THIS AS IF IT
DOESN'T MATTER?
THEY HAVE SO LOW EXPECTATIONS
FOR HER THAT THEY DON'T CALL HER
ON IT.
>> IT'S NOT JUST PATRONIZING.
IT WOULD BE DIFFERENT IF THEY
WERE SILENT ON ALL THESE
INSTANCES OF RACISM.
WHEN IT COMES TO DONALD TRUMP,
HE DOESN'T HAVE TO SAY ANYTHING
THAT'S ACTUALLY RACIST.
IN THEIR MINDS, THEY CAN FORM
SOMETHING THAT IS RACIST.
IF YOU SUPPORT THEM, YOU ARE AN
EVIL PERSON.
IF YOU HAVE CLEAR EVIDENCE OF
RACISM AND THERE ARE COMPLETELY
SILENT ON THIS.
IT'S A BUNCH OF HYPOCRISY WITH
THE PRESS.
THAT'S WHY THEIR APPROVAL RATING
IS SO LOW RIGHT NOW WITH
AMERICAN PEOPLE BECAUSE I DON'T
TRUST AT THE PRESS.
>> Tucker: IT'S LIKE TED
KENNEDY COULD KILL A WOMAN AND
STILL BE CONSIDERED A GREAT
FEMINIST.
HERE'S HIS PICTURE WHICH WAS
HIDDEN FROM VIEW.
IT WAS CONSIDERED TOO
INFLAMMATORY FOR THE REST OF US
TO SEE.
THE PRESS HIT IT FROM US.
DON'T YOU THINK WE SHOULD HAVE
HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE OUR
OWN JUDGMENTS ABOUT THAT?
>> WE SHOULD HAVE HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY.
THE MEDIA AROUND CHICAGO KNEW
ABOUT THIS.
THE NATION OF ISLAM HEADQUARTERS
IS IN CHICAGO.
THEY WERE KNOWN TO HANG OUT WITH
THESE ELECTED OFFICIALS.
THE QUESTION IS, NOT ONLY DID
THEY SHIELD THIS PHOTO, BUT WHY
WOULD THE PRESS REFUSED TO
REPORT ON IT?
ANYBODY THAT WORKED IN CHICAGO
KNEW THAT THEY HUNG OUT
TOGETHER, THAT THEY REFUSED TO
TELL THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
>> Tucker: ACCORDING TO A
NATION OF ISLAM GUY WE TALKED TO
NATION OF ISLAM GUY WE TALKED T
TO, AND HERE WORKING IN A SENATE
OFFICE.
IT'S LIKE --